even in times of a national tragedy the
liberal media won't let up on President
Trump it's unreal they're now attacking
him for going to visit survivors of
Sunday's deadly Massacre and even more
despicable stereotyping the victims as
Trump voters
here's CNN reporter Jeff Zeleny of
course Las Vegas is a town that he is
connected to and in and knows well his
name is emblazoned on the top of a hotel
there as well he campaigned there a lot
so this is something that I'm not
surprised at all to see him go there
visiting early something else I think to
a keep in mind a lot of these country
music supporters were likely Trump
supporters and this is something that of
course is hitting the tapestry of all
Americans and there are going to be
victims from across the country here so
the president's visiting a city with his
hotel in it and just because the victims
were maybe country music fans yeah what
are you saying yeah you know
unintentionally this is kind of
interesting what he just did
what is he suggesting that maybe they're
being targeted for that that that this
could have been like a Scalise shooting
that they were targeted because they
might maybe this was a biscut he's
basically saying a country music
festival is like a trump rally and I
mean he he probably didn't mean that but
by by linking it to Trump he kind of did
that it's kind of interesting like he's
basically saying could the killer have
been liberal is what he's saying I'm
sorry but if he's gonna say look CNN
does this CNN will find any link whether
it's you know Charlotte's felt they will
find a link you could find a link from
that he's been a reporter for a very
long time I took a little bit
differently I think what was happening
was doing a live shot and they get the
word from the White House that the
president is going to go to Vegas on
Wednesday so he's in a live shot trying
to explain why the president would
actually go and do that and he's make I
don't think that he intended to make
some derogatory correlation he had that
he was only going because I was in Vegas
right because there this morning he
hasn't I feel like you said stuff like
that before maybe I'm wrong research
well it seems to me that he was trying
to build a case for why the president's
going so quickly there and didn't go so
quickly elsewhere and and I think that's
all it was but
you know it touches on such a sore point
at this moment I mean you did I mean I
would I would have stayed away from but
I think there are lots of people who do
think that the country music fans are in
fact big people who are always talking
Second Amendment alike and that this
tragedy befell them and then they say oh
my gosh but that's not why the president
would visit them quickly Kimberly right
yeah
no the point is the president would go
to Las Vegas because it was the worst
mass shooting American history is
everybody like can we wake up and take
the smelling salts and realize that
that's a situation and stop trying to
politicize it and these are wonderful
people all from different diverse
backgrounds so what if they like country
music
fantastic they're also from all
different states all different states
some from Canada etc and an hour before
that they were singing god Bless America
in unison so you know god bless them and
we pray and you know rest their souls
and for their families